it takes a show a while to get the kinks
out and the big bang theory is no
exception
here are all the weird things you might
not have realized about the first
episode of the big bang theory
the first scene in the first episode of
the big bang theory begins with the
setting never seen on the series again
and broaching a topic that's never
explored further
concerned about growing old before
passing on their science genius genes
sheldon and leonard visit a sperm bank
one not only accepts the genetic
material of the highly intelligent and
exceptional while that's very much in
character with sheldon's outspoken
vanity and pride in his superior
intellect
it clashes mightily with how he's
depicted for most of the rest of the
series
which is somewhat adverse to any and all
kinds of sexual and physical behavior
it's a little weird to see the almost
always libido free sheldon openly talk
about
and be open to providing a sample of a
sperm bank it's even stranger later in
the episode when the famously awkward
sheldon considers the possibility of
coupling up with penny
in the same way that sheldon is more of
a red-blooded sexual being than he'd
wind up being for most of the big bang
theory penny isn't quite
right at the beginning of the show she
moves in across the hall from leonard
and sheldon and the former is smitten
with her after their first meeting
sure she's conventionally attractive but
penny is also very likable
she's friendly she's bubbly and she's
curious about her new building mates
this isn't the penny that kaylee cuoco
would play later on
before long penny would get a lot less
lively and a lot more cynical
perhaps hanging out with all those fussy
exhausting high maintenance nerds day in
and day out
killed her spirit along with that tiring
job as a chain restaurant waitress and
demoralizing ultimately failed career as
an actress
plus penny defies the stereotypical dumb
blonde archetype she's supposed to
embody by revealing in the pilot that
she's written screenplay
the idea of penny's potential double
threats as a performer and a writer is
never mentioned again and her
screenwriting talents were quickly
abandoned
maybe the most notable thing about the
first episode of the big bang theory
isn't what's there but what isn't there
or rather who is it nearly half of the
show's core long-term cast members
weren't yet a part of the series
kevin sussman didn't make his first
appearance as sad sack comic store owner
stewards until the end of season two
melissa roush didn't join the series as
microbiologist bernadette rostinkowski
until the start of season three
and mayam bialik didn't portray
neurologist amy farah fowler until the
end of season 3.
that means none of them show up or even
merida mentioned in the first episode of
the big bang theory
that gives the episode a sparse feel
it's just really quiet and simple with
only 5 main characters
plus after so many episodes about
romantic entanglements sheldon and amy
howard and bernadette leonard and penny
it's the rare episode of the big bang
theory that isn't entirely about a
couple
the big bang theory could be
characterized as a quick moving rapid
fire show
the setups and punch lines come at the
viewer fast as do scene changes with
that distinctive transitional graphic of
an atomic model accompanied by a whoosh
sound effect
plus the average big bang episode
incorporates a lot of scenes at several
locations
generally including the main apartment
set the one across the hall some caltech
offices the cafeteria
howard and bernadette's house and a few
other spots however that formats in its
fast flow weren't in place in the first
episode
the pilot feels more like a play clearly
separated into three acts and only a
handful of scenes
and they're all about as long as the
scene can be in a half hour sitcom
the episode begins with a pre-theme song
cold open that stretches to a whopping
six minute scene
after that it's on to the guy's
apartment where the vast majority of the
episode takes place
based on his behavior in the first
episode of the big bang theory it's hard
to get a handle on raj kutherpali
no trace of his future character arcs
are present not his desire for a grand
and epic romance nor his slow acceptance
of his own fate and his move away from
dependence on his wealthy parents
that's because raj a main character in
most episodes of the big bang theory has
about two lines in the show's pilot
episode
wait until you see this it's fantastic
unbelievable this is explained away with
this early quirk of being too shy to
talk to women without the aid of
alcoholic beverages
but still it's odd and surprising that
he barely talks
raj even dresses differently wearing a
baseball cap with his regular nerdy
outfit
although many ingredients that would
make the big bang theory such a
resounding long-running success weren't
yet present in the show's first episode
the writers did show some foresight
like other situation comedies about
groups of young friends the big bang
theory is about a social group that
forms a de facto family
and it evoked that idea week after week
by having the whole gang gathering to
eat together like a family dinner
it was a powerful statement and the cast
eating takeout with one another became
one of the definitive enduring images of
the big bang theory over the years
it was also the very last scene of the
very last episode of the series
creating a parallel with the first
episode where sheldon and leonard
invited penny into their family by
asking her to eat with them
oh you're inviting me over to eat uh
yes oh that's so nice i'd love to
plus in the pilot episode leonard
watches penny walk away and then he
proclaims they will one day have babies
that quote
will be smart and beautiful thanks to
their meshed jeans
in the finale married penny and leonard
learn they've got a baby on the way
though sheldon mocked leonard for this
declaration in the pilot he uses his
nobel prize acceptance speech in the
finale to note that his friend was right
he said to me that their babies would be
smart and beautiful
and now that they're expecting i have no
doubt that that will be the case
check out one of our newest videos right
here plus even more looper videos about
your favorite tv shows are coming soon
subscribe to our youtube channel and hit
the bell so you don't miss a single one
you